vile indefensible murderous racist
criminal Liam Neeson's possibly
career-ending comments about his desire
to wreak revenge on any black man he
could find following the rape of a close
friend are as bad as you can get I'm not
seeking to defend those remarks however
they reflect something that didn't
happen 40 years ago have none of us ever
had some evil thoughts once in our lives
that we did not act on or in our modern
world are we to be defined by our
mistakes
however despicable forever a couple of
things yeah so first of all I don't know
if you noticed but this was quite a big
week for stories about racism in Britain
because there was a report about the
levels of harassment and bullying that
black female professors are experiencing
there was a debate among some members of
the Conservative Party about why they
can't use the word [ __ ] because they
think they should be allowed to there
was a deportation of charter flight that
was deporting black British people one
of whom at least actually had a British
passport was deported was nearly
deported anyway part of the whole wind
rush thing that is still ongoing that
seeing black which people talk to the
deportation and then there was the story
about Liam Neeson yeah now I find it
interesting that Liam Neeson confessing
that he had these racist thoughts was
the thing that everyone was interested
in rather than the very real ongoing
experiences of people who are facing
racism in this country and I feel like I
have some personal experience about this
because I wrote a book which came out
this time last year which I talked about
my experiences of racism and why I think
it's healthy for us to have a
conversation about it and you know what
was so fascinating is that the same
people who have jumped to defend Liam
Neeson are the ones who told me that I
was being a victim by talking about it
and now suddenly a Hollywood actor comes
out and says he had these racist
thoughts and they say oh it's great that
he talked about it and it's really
healthy to have a conversation can I
just start you before I go to the rest
of the panel I hear all the above I
didn't know about the black professors I
didn't know about the P word and
apologies if anyone was offended but is
mr. Neeson forever to be defined by that
that was that's my key
I think it would be a different
conversation if he admitted and
reflected on the reasons why he had
those thoughts which he hasn't done he
says he regrets being vengeful right the
question I have is his best female
friend he described came and told him
she'd been raped which is as I'm sure we
all agree a horrible thing to happen
both to her and to him right I mean the
first thing he said to her was what
color was he okay okay why did you get
such a racialized way and secondly when
he then had this murderous thought about
any black person yes he hasn't reflected
on what is it about our society that
would make some of react in such a
racialized way that by the way plays
into a very established history of
blaming all the black people of the
crimes of one I just want to play a book
exactly what he said so we can see it
for ourselves I was away and I came back
and she told me she had been raped but
she handled the situation of the rape
that was extraordinary way but my
immediate reaction was I asked did she
know either what wasn't done what color
were they she said it was a black person
I have an up and down areas with a cosh
hoping I'd be approached by somebody I'm
ashamed to say that and I did it for
maybe a week hoping some black would
come out of a pub I never go at me about
something you know so that I could kill
him I'm not clear at all how his
reflecting on this has led him to an
understanding of why we think in such a
racialized way and for black people when
they hear that it reminds us of a
history where we were rounded up and
punished for things that had nothing to
do with us I just want to play one more
thing quickly this is collector Okafor
who is a black women often comments on
these issues and I completely agree with
what she has to say have a listen
historically speaking there's been so
much violence and rape towards black
women where black men had to stand by
and watch
due to colonisation due to this
transatlantic slave trade yet we don't
find that black men are going out
looking for random white men who had
nothing to do with it to kill even
though entire family lines were started
from rape so it's it's really
be problematic that Liam would think
that any black man could pay for the
crimes of a single black man because
we're not expecting that of any other
race I feel like I can say from personal
experience but when as a black person
you raise this you're told you have a
chip on your shoulder if you don't like
it here leave when someone like Liam
Neeson says he had a racist thought this
huge wave an outpouring of sympathy okay
thank you let's get Rachel up that and I
take on board all those points what I'm
trying to expose is this ever hanging
over his head I think it's unfortunate
for Liam Neeson that he was doing an
interview to promote a film about
revenge and you know one of the good
things about this may be that we don't
have to endure endless actors being
interviewed about their films anymore
because this has been a complete
catastrophe for that movie they've
canceled the premiere on the other hand
you know it was 40 years ago you can
hear the shame in his voice and he says
he is ashamed now are we gonna take a
man down for what was essentially a
thought Crowley I don't think we should
well I don't think it should be a one
strike and you're out that even the well
my dear we don't necessarily know it's
been interesting that two black people
have come out thoughtfully to defend
Liam Neeson and their woopy Goldberg and
they are John Barnes yeah who I know
well and he is not a man who shoots from
the hip do I agree with what John Barnes
said I did I don't think this is a
black-and-white haha issue let's hear
what John for those who didn't they're
not come straight back to you Rachel and
I feel I'm going to bring you this is
what Jon Vance said he said he was
horrified and ashamed for thinking that
but that is not the story were telling
we now want him to be pilloried we want
us to never let him work again people
are now going to be afraid to tell the
truth on how they feel and I always say
we are all unconscious racist and he
said unconsciously for a week and a half
that's how we felt we have people who've
been doing it and keeping it quiet for
20 years but as long as you don't admit
it then we think everything is okay
he's ashamed and embarrassed by it so
why he'd been pilloried for it forming
land football player there john barnes
rachel quick response to that just very
quickly I was once held up at gunpoint
by two black men and when I go out into
the street I don't think are they should
I be careful of black man I think should
I be careful of men that does that make
me guilty of sex
ISM you noted that I admit that when I
am in the street and I tell my daughter
be careful of men I mean it's the same
sort of thing what's good for today we
have got a collective unconscious and
that was now I think Lisa near as
basically said something that's
incredibly stupid all right
he's gonna regret it I don't think he
should be shot down for the rest of his
life about it because people make
mistakes and everybody deserves the
chance to be rehabilitated in some way
shape or form but when he opened his gob
it's almost as if he opened it and was
enrolled of what he was in the film
Leeson you are not a steely-eyed bringer
of death you're an actor you're nothing
so those thoughts that you say you were
having are probably only four so for
that reason and that reason only what he
was actually saying it's probably just
to promote this film I'm not sure that
what he said was incredibly stupid I
think that what he said was incredibly
honest now
it was incredibly honest and it was very
wrong and he himself has admitted that
it was wrong he himself has said that
he's moved pasta and I don't think
there's anyone in the land and that
would advocate what he was suggesting so
if we all put that to one side and we
all acknowledge it was a wrong thought
that he had he shouldn't have had it and
hopefully you know he doesn't have those
thoughts anymore so if you just pack
that with one cycle prowling about
looking for someone to kill you would
have done your own now if you promote a
new film I didn't because I didn't make
my point so my point is if we all
conclude that there's kind of things you
shouldn't say then we put that to the
side because it was wrong everyone
agrees my words we have this culture of
social justice warriors who sit in the
wings and they are absolutely determined
they go through years of people's
previous things and I'm moving on from
the lamb kneels somethingyou I'm not
talking about him anymore moved on to
talk about the general issue of this
they go through years where four
people's back catalogs of stuff
desperately hoping to bring people down
that they jealous of or that for some
reason they have a gender against and
they throw up stuff from don't care that
you thought in the Oscars not that long
ago there's people having to resign from
girls because it stopped they said that
when there was 15 years old well we have
seen too many times people who have
actually done good work leonie's
some great work being taken down and
being canceled in the phrase is used now
by people who sit in judgment and say
right you're over but there's been a sky
data poll done on whether Liam Neeson
was right or wrong and let's have a
quick look at that forty four percent
say he was right to make his admission
and thirty percent said he was wrong I
just think he was absolutely idiotic he
was to admit to this you're gonna create
a culture of I don't agree with what
you're all saying I don't think he has
apologized for fully acknowledged he
dated then he was wrong to be vengeful
he hasn't said I had racist thoughts
I've thought about where they come from
now I have a better understanding of the
way racism works on a psychologically
you know I'm sure you're talking about
the kind of social Joshu people we never
talk about why it is that people have
these look so I know where they come
from if a black person commits a crime
it's black on black crime it's a Muslim
it's a beautiful it's muslim paedophiles
we have a society that racialized his
crime and racialized as whole groups for
the actions of one he is manifesting
that and instead of talking about that
we're just so busy explaining these are
usually punished enough he is the victim
of this crime isn't instead and
punishing him i'm interested in learning
from what he did he hasn't learned from
it we're not black people talk about
their own experiences personal
experiences that strain of racism we are
not listening to people to have the
intellectual curiosity or the humility
to realize that so we have an experience
that's the thing is rigid oppressive we
just don't know where where it happened
we know everything if it was in
Ballymena forty years ago he's probably
never going to listen i'm afraid we have
to move on from steely eyed bringers of
death to Carmageddon